what's been the hardest lesson for you
to learn in your life but I can't do
everything what are things you would
love to be doing that you're not doing
nothing you would rather be doing
nothing or you know there's correct
there is nothing I'm in full control of
my life there's something I want to do
that I can go do it we make our beds so
I sleep in it what do you think about
your employees do you think they all
share the same ideology that you do
about doing everything that it is they
want to be doing absolutely not
why do you think that is because I think
people are wired differently and I think
I have to and I don't even want all I
want to do is react to what they want
and how they aspire to be or what
they're interested in I have no interest
in them being like me
or not being like me I'm in the reaction
business and so I just think people are
hardwired I don't think everybody was as
lucky to have the mother that told them
that they could do anything and actually
make them believe it and that's
unfortunate and I hope through example
and content I'm able to inspire that but
I think I think practicality is grossly
underrated and for all my sizzle I'm
obsessed with the steak
[Music]